every year was a goodbye every year we
said goodbye to the crew we said goodbye
to each other and then may
the upfronts
you would hear apparently
they gave rob a call and said we might
be coming back and then it so you're
always rebooking that show and then
moving back out so it's a [ __ ]
upheaval you i've lived in you live in a
different apartment every time yeah
with the same [ __ ] leasing agents
trying to get a furnished plate we're
all just interchanging yeah one's over
there in yale town and then the other
one's over he's just doing the same [ __ ]
mix it up yeah just mix it up and then
when i auditioned i got out of that when
i auditioned for bly manor it was uh
england i believe was the audition and i
was like okay i'm i'll work at home i'll
go back and work and i book it and
uh from a tape that i just did and and
um i got the part of blind manner and
then my agent called me and she was
giggling
you're going back again back to
vancouver and i was [ __ ] done by the
end of my zombie which was february and
this was
august i want to say i got the call
and
i
i was like okay it's fine it's a good
job it's mike flynn again it's netflix
i'll be fine and
i went up there and then on my first day
mike kind of did this size up thing and
said something
that made me feel like oh i'm being
sized up for something else
and then he did it again
and then he asked me something another
time is like how old do you reckon you
could play like how was that what's the
max you reckon you could you could
legitimately play and i was like late
30s early 40s and he's like okay and at
some point i reached out to mike and i
was like what's going on
and he was like let's have a meeting and
i flew back to la and sat down with him
and he pitched me midnight mass
in november so i'd only and i'd only
worked on him he only directed the pilot
of bligh so he only saw you for the
pilot
and then offered you the part for
midnight mass yeah and he was like can
you do an american accent i was like
nope but that didn't matter you didn't
know i've never thought you learned one
kinda that was perfect thanks man yeah i
know i didn't know you were english
you